[Music]
all right so uh in recent news there's a
Chicago man named Nico who is now suing
27 women one man damn 20 different parts
of the Facebook Corporation wow patreon
GoFundMe and the website are we
datingthe
same.com for claiming that they're
responsible for damages incurred when
women posted online about alleged
negative experiences they had on with
him in in quote are we dating the same
guy Facebook group
wa explain that a lot you could actually
do that okay so basically there are
hundreds of quote are we dating the same
guy groups on Facebook for different
cities around the world and it's
basically a website or a place to sus it
out yeah it's literally it's a mini
Black Book of Facebook right so it's
like if somebody [__] Burns you type
[__] a woman might go onto this Facebook
group hey are we dating the same guy and
they're checking out they're like this
person did this to me ghost me XYZ
whatever and and then another girl might
be like yo I want to kind of like vet
this dude let me go into this city are
we dating the same guy they're going to
find a post based on or profile on a
certain person and they're going to be
like this guy did XYZ and then they can
cancel those dates or whatever get the
tea right so this guy has been posted on
such Facebook group many times to the
point where he's suing for defamation
damn he's a player in a sense yeah
career playoff so in his case according
to his complaint women use the Chicago
based group already in the guy to say
quote he's clingy and goes to them after
sleeping with them he's been posted here
before the poster said he sent her a
slew of text calling her names because
she didn't want to spend the night with
him and they going up his game yeah I
mean wow yeah Dam I mean it's kind of
fair yeah yeah yeah I already don't
trust him cuz you can't clingy and you
ghost them after having sex yeah that's
or you cuss them out if they don't sleep
with you well don't work together
different brands yeah yeah it's like
one's a simp and one's a player
different MOS man yeah that's weird they
are they are that is that is a that
should be the reason why he wins though
right he should win they're blowing up
his whole game for like but that's not
consistent if he gets a down ass judge
okay what if he's a simp to a really hot
girl and he's a player to a eh girl yeah
see I get it same guy two different
experiences now you're blowing up
everyone's game now you know what I'm
talking about it's called being a bigger
man I agree I was wrong and I take it
back you're welcome sorry go ahead
people are also calling him quote a
psycho in the group according to uh the
complaint he and the but they all date
originally posted about him met
organically at a cultural event in
Chicago and briefly communicated with
one another plaintiff and defendant
engaged in consensual sexual intercourse
on the evening they first met o the
party spent brief periods of time
together on a handful of occasions which
were unremarkable and the parties never
engaged in an exclusive dating
relationship defendants broadcast their
outrageous cruel and malicious lies
about the plaintiff with knowledge that
the statements were false or with
Reckless disregard as whether or not
they were true so that's basically the
plaintive also being like yo that's
that's pure defamation that's Notting
exactly if there's like 27 plus people
yeah [__] posting similar things about a
person you're probably a [__] scum
bag probably 27 I mean well I mean
they're sleep they're actually sleeping
with 27 women and one guy so are they
just heartbroken after he like bouncing
they being but hurt about it well what's
the one guy for he slept with a guy
too that's a good question the guy's
like he made my [__] Soul
sore and then he didn't talk to me again
his dick was too big for an [__]
that's got to be the troll in the Forum
it's like if Steve got in there he's
like I also know him yeah you destroyed
by a butthole he's cool he's cool with
all the chicks talking [__] and he sees
the one guy trolling and he's like this
is too far I got to [__] make a l
probably messing around and then they
ended up making taking it to court now
he's like a [__] I got to show up well
it's you you said it was 21 women and
one guy 27 and one guy right so what the
the guy I had to create a story for the
guy they totally they totally subpoena a
Troll's IP address and then he's like oh
he's like God damn
it it was pretty funny we got to cry
with them all together and
[__] [__] man got to play it up take
photos of like bruised [__] go
[__] Bali together from now on oh man
okay yeah I don't know I think if you're
doing numbers like that you're just
finding the best marks I don't think
he's like I I wouldn't call him as bad
what are what are the accusations though
we don't know that's and that's the
cruel thing because I think like like
women definitely just need to
be a little bit more Vigilant at like
figuring out which guys are shitty
without tools like this yeah also when
it says the the one of the uh you know
people who complained on the Facebook
group um they like went out for a date
and met and had sex that same night it's
like sex on the first day too it's like
you know that's dangerous yeah like you
don't know what after there could be a
killer yeah yeah yeah you don't even
know or it could or you could just get
your heart broken that's the more thing
that happens well the fact is they're
all sleeping with them right so it's
like well that doesn't make it okay but
to me that makes it questionable I'm
like does no one see the red flag you're
still bulletproof from a like this if
you just don't do that yeah don't
[__] sleep with them like so quickly
but then they're like oh but he's so
clingy and I'm like he's [__] you on
the first day I know he's not clingy
he's clingy he's a [__] record
[__] laugh you can't handle his game
[__] he's gone where's the cling made
you night one that makes no sense you
[__] him on the first date yeah and then
you can't get rid of him cuz he's
annoying but then you want to talk [__]
about him and still talk about him CU
it's an amalgamation of everybody's
complaints it doesn't make
so even if he's not totally wrong in a
sense or they're not totally right at
the same time are they totally wrong for
just having a Facebook group of like
probably not no it's that isn't that
freedom of speech though I think people
should have a Yelp about them that's
what they do that's what girls do some
it's [__] it yeah you're right 100%
think about JK Yelp JK Yelp would be
wild hey I think we'd have a 4.5 star I
look I'm just saying that some reviews
would be unfair but we have a lot of we
have more positive than negative and I
think that's what counts yeah yeah I
think it's good to have a review that
way you could work on it but you ever
watch that Sherlock Holmes Show you ever
watch the Sherlock Holmes Show with
Benedict cumman oh yeah it's called
Sherlock so thank you so he would see
all this together and he go n something
off something off about this [__] yeah
but then he would see a bunch of like
[__] invisible numbers and random
details highlighted and stuff like that
at the same time yeah super cut he would
super cut all that [__] yeah bill bagin
was his assistant oh yeah he was good
too
great show great show it's hard to tell
if this guy's a scumbag from just this
but I do think it's good to have some
type of profile on how crazy someone
might be you know what I mean like it's
like the it's like the dating world it's
like can be crazy right but you want to
know from other guys and girls it's like
is this [__]
crazy. it's really good the thing is
that that I find weird is that if 27
people found each other that they had
all [__] this guy what good has this
thing done if they already [__] him in
true they weren't it makes sense if none
of them [__] them and they're like I
went on a date with this [__]
and he was crazy and he was restaurant
and you're like I got a tummy ache and
thenone like no [__] [__] yeah that's
why I think but I ate there
anyways and I ordered and I waited I
think if you're like stuck in this
already it's like the point of this is
clearly it's like it's like keeping up
the Kardashians it's like this is just
what you like to do you like to connect
on a guy that you hate and you all [__]
them it's like a thing that yeah it's
like a fun thing to do it's it was not a
preventative measure of like we're going
to keep girls safe it's like no you're
not no you're not it's them [__] and
Jerry McGuire at the end I see bitching
about men 20 girls were just Libras and
one dude was Libra too ah it's the
Libras it's the Libras them Libras man
Libras and and they all have period at
the same time what if they all you on
your I'm on mine and it just
connected cuz you you never see that
from a Virgo girl no you don't it's
always them Libras it's a Libras plus
this guy he's just like short-term
scamming them like heartbreak cell he's
not taking their money he's not getting
them time he says anything about that
those are the guys they should be
worried about this guy's just in and out
he's just gone like yeah but he's not
marrying you and then [__] marrying
someone else in China it's like that's
yeah these are bigger problems in this
these are B Gemini [__] who are like
I thought they were Libras no no there
may be Gemini to here's my case hold on
I'm Gemini they can't wait to go out on
a date with you and then they turn on
your the next date and they go oh he's
clingy he's so [__] weird and he
won't call me back is it because they
got dropped after so they have to turn
it around like oh he hit it and quit it
but like I'm top 10 [__] so there's no
way and and and the sad part is is the
fact that all these women came together
and have such different definitions of
the guy that means he's none of those
things and he's all of those things cuz
he's choosing who he is with every girl
that he [__] so you have to give him a
little bit of credit that's pretty
[__] crazy hate the game yeah he's a
player H so so at the end of the day
none of them know him at all no but he's
player one that's for D I think shap
shifting what's worse than this are the
guys that go on dates and then get food
and then walk out that's worse than this
yeah yeah you're right you're right he's
scum but he's level one scum he's not
litigation scum he's just your typical I
don't think he should sue either sh up
yeah but then afterward are like this
guy's weird he is suing though so he's
like a little bit scum yeah but then
that I think is also stupid like he's
just offended at that point are they
posting his pictures everywhere is it is
it [__] up his game is that why his
pictures posting his profile everywhere
that he's like [__] you guys are ruining
my game well if he's [__] like 27
girls and one guy that means his body
count is pretty successful and what
happened is that what ended up happening
is that this now ruined his he's like
hey how come I'm not matching that much
on [__] anymore and then they see it
and he goes That's why these [__]
[__] blocking [__] he just got to go
to another city so he's in a different
Facebook group cuz that's like serial
how did GoFundMe measure into any of
this stuff I have no idea maybe somebody
getting donations from my cancer now
hell me Sue yeah yeah maybe it's that
he's s weet gofund me though right one
of those guys was a simp so hard that
he's like I'll just [__] this guy and
get him out of my way get him out of my
way [__] through him [__] yeah well what
if it was to get to the next level like
he wanted to [__] his friend oh and
she's hot but then he's all like you got
to get through me first I'm like the
[__] I'm like the right hand man boss
he is yeah the guy is kind of right
though that like you know nowadays when
you do a review on a product for
something you have to have a verified
purchase oh yeah yeah yeah that kind of
needs something similar oh you got take
a picture of him asleep or something
like that one dude huh that's crazy 27
and is there more things in there that
you're not telling us Anthony nothing of
importance are you hiding some sneaky
information yeah and then you're going
to twist it on us like he's actually a
serial rapist or something like that
that's what he would do on on half an
don't turn this into a patreon video
half an day he tries to pull sneaky
things you called it half an day you've
acknowledged me I feel seen I feel seen
you coined
[Music]
it